[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une situation inédite à cette
échelle depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale si vous demandez si poutine est
capable d'utiliser des armes chimiques
je pense qu'il pourrait utiliser
n'importe quoi dans la situation dans
laquelle il est actuellement les
critiques le bombardement du centre
international pour le maintien de la
paix et la sécurité a tué 35 personnes
et à seulement 20 km de là se trouvent
les frontières de l'otan
ils seront août et je le répète encore
une fois si vous ne verrouille et pas
notre ciel ce n'est qu'une question de
temps les roquettes russes vont tomber
sur votre territoire sur le territoire
de l'otan bien mieux que la fiction les
effets spéciaux des scènes de guerre
terrifiante en plein paris c'est ce qu'a
posté le parlement ukrainien vendredi
soir avec ce message menaçant vous
croyez que ça ne vous concerne pas la
russie ne s'arrêtera pas si nous tombons
vous tomberez sont des images chocs et
des images qui vise à attirer voilà
attirer les pays européens en soutien de
l'ukraine c'est toujours très choquant 1
mais bien sûr que moi je suis aux côtés
aux côtés du président zine ski
lorsque notre zemmour dit la guerre nous
distrait de la campagne lorsque madame
pécresse dit que le président se cache
derrière la campagne je crois que ce
sont des personnalités qui croit qu'on
est face à un fait divers en relais face
à un fait historique et donc évidemment
au moment où je m'adresse à vous
aujourd'hui je le fais en en sollicitant
à nouveau votre confiance votre
confiance pour les cinq années qui
viennent selon le new york times moscou
aurait demandé à pékin de lui fournir
des équipements militaires et une aide
économique mise en garde ir des états
unis
communiquons directement en privé avec
pékin il y aura des conséquences pour ce
qui est de la russie à contourner les
sanctions à grande échelle dans la ville
de donetsk une frappe ukrainienne a fait
au moins 16 morts selon les séparatistes
pro-russes depuis quelques temps les
états unis font de la désinformation
envers la chine de ce qui concerne à la
question ukrainienne ils l'ont fait à
maintes reprises et avec de mauvaises
intentions ils disent avoir intercepté
un missile contenant des sous munitions
armes interdites en effet par plus d'une
centaine de pays c'est un missile à sous
munitions il a explosé en l'air ce qui
explique la dispersion des éclats de
part et d'autre sur chacun de ces
immeubles avec des dégâts considérables
le coville justement c'est à la une de
beaucoup de vos journaux on raccroche
les masques et nous dit par exemple
dauphiné libéré idem à la une du journal
du centre avec ce titre bas les masques
l'épidémie n'est pas fini ce nom est là
on la question on à vannes depuis
quelques jours une légère augmentation
qui n'est pas seulement en france
d'exercer sur l'ensemble des pays
européens les contaminations repartent à
la hausse au moins trois raisons
expliquent leur pont de l'épidémie la
levée progressive des restrictions le
moindre respect des gestes barrières
chacun d'entre nous nous avons baissé la
garde un peu il ya une diminution des
précautions qui sont faites ancien bras
droit de marine le pen a décidé
d'apporter son soutien à nicolas dupont
aignan en 2010 est celui ci avait
rejoint marine le pen entre les deux
tours leur avons demandé à tous les deux
s'il ne regrettait pas d'avoir rompu
avec la candidate du rassemblement
national retour du confinement en chine
plusieurs villes du pays sont à nouveau
sous strict confinement une seule
personne par foyer est autorisé à sortir
une fois tous les deux jours on parlait
de marine le pen d'eric zemmour des
autres on en parle tellement que on va
pas en parler ici enfin pour moi
[Musique]
ce lundi signe la fin d'une contrainte
mais peut-être le début de déconvenues
[Musique]